Let's look at the solution
to our virtual memory quiz.
We said that the computer
has 16 active applications,
each with a 32-bit address space.
So each potentially sees
a four gigabyte memory.
What is the real memory in the system?
It turns out that all of these
are potentially correct.
We can have a system that has only
two 2-gigabyte memory modules.
So it really has a total of
4 gigabytes physical memory.
Yet it can run 16 applications,
each of which thinks that it
has 4 gigabytes of memory.
We can also have more memory,
even more memory,
a different combination of memory and
so on.
So pretty much what the applications
think they have in terms of memory and
what the system really has can be
completely decoupled by virtual memory.